let's talk to larry who's calling from
29 palms california on the democrat line
larry good morning
good morning yeah um i served 20 years
the united states marine corps believe
me january 6 is going to go down in
history the problem was is we saw it on
tv now i know you're not a patriotic
person you're like trump
talk out both sides of your mouth you
never served this country he bowed down
to russia
the
the congressman the senators the
governors they all won their seats on
the same ballot this guy trump made a
full up can i just ask a question
how did trump bow down to russia oh you
know
yeah he bowed down to russia come on he
would do this to january 6 to make
russia be happy
to how how would how would january 6
make russia be happy your country white
people are not from america you guys are
from russia europe england so straighten
up or get white people are not from
america
what
he hung up so go ahead
michael
that was the most interesting call i've
had in a long time thank you for your
service though you know this is this is
something that's really difficult
because
the the caller calls in and he says i
served in the marine corps which is a
wonderful thing
thanks for doing that that's a great
thing to do but then to to
uh use that and to say as a result half
of this country is
uh traitorous and treasonous and that's
that's a really ugly thing and we're not
going to be able to
we're not going to be able to have a
good flourishing stable country
if one half thinks the other side is a
bunch of traders and terrorists who
ought to be expelled to the outer
darkness where there's wailing and
gnashing of teeth that's not not not a
good way to start a political dialogue
to fight back against big tech's assault
on truth justice in the american way
all of my rights on the internet i use
expressvpn on all of my devices you ever
wonder how free to access tech giants
make all of their money you think are
they a charity they're just doing it out
of the goodness of their heart no they
make their money by tracking your
searches and your video history and
everything you click on and then they
build a profile on you and then they
sell that profile and all your sensitive
data to the highest bidder when you use
the expressvpn app on your computer or
phone you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity much more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers what's
more expressvpn encrypts 100 of your
network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals
what i like most is how easy it is to
use
i'm something of a luddite myself i put
it on my browser i put it on my phone
boom boom just click the button it's
done stop allowing big tech to revoke
your rights why not revoke their right
to your data instead secure your
internet with the vpn that i trust for
online protection that would be
expressvpn.com
michael yt
e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn
michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-y-t to get three extra
months free with my exclusive link
what's that address expressvpn.com
michael yt right now to learn more let's
go to jill who's calling from woodward
iowa on the democrat line jill good
morning
good morning um and uh
have a great day today uh my big
question is is i really resent him using
the word trivial related to um january 6
i don't think if you were talking to
brian sicknick's parents you would be
using the word trivial
um and i i think i would
there were there's about a hundred all
of the ptsd and the injuries of the
capitol police officers that was trivial
so i'll i'll use your first example
because i think it highlights the huge
disconnect here between
americans on this issue of january 6.
you said that if you were talking to the
parents of brian siknik the officer who
was allegedly killed by the capitol
rioters that you would you would not be
able to call it trivial
the idea that the capitol rioters killed
officer brian sicknick is a complete lie
it was totally made up even the
left-wing newspapers such as the new
york times had to admit that
it didn't happen the capitol rioters
didn't kill anybody there was one person
killed in the political violence of
january 6th her name was ashley babbitt
she was one of the capital rioters she
was killed by a trigger happy cop so i i
i don't mean to impugn your motives in
any way or the motives of of many
americans who are clutching their pearls
and who earnestly and sincerely believe
that the capital riot was the worst
attack in our nation's history
it just simply wasn't you have been fed
a bunch of propaganda that even many of
the propagandists have since corrected
but the problem is they run the story
that brian sicknick was killed by the
capitol riders on page a1 of the
newspaper and they run the retraction on
page z1000 so so nobody really sees that
especially if you're only tuned into cnn
or msnbc or reading the the left-wing
papers
that this is why i would say that i mean
this is why i bring up the comparison of
blm because you you don't need to look
back at the many other attacks on the
u.s capitol
almost all of which have been much more
significant than the the january 6th
capital riot you don't even have to go
that far back you can just go back to
the blm riots when propagandists from
the left-wing cable news outlets were
saying that buildings on fire were fiery
but mostly peaceful protests last time i
checked when you're firebombing
buildings that's not mostly peaceful
if you just compare the numbers capital
rioters kill nobody blm kills dozens of
people it's quite clear that the blm
insurrection if you want to use that
word they were attacking federal
buildings was far more significant it
led to far more policy changes it was
defended by actual elected democrats now
people who were are the vice president
president of the united states
that is going to
not only matter much more in itself but
it's going to have a much longer term
effect on american history whereas the
significance of the january 6th capital
riot is only going to matter in the
mythology that the the left creates
about it and already has created about
it to justify further uh incursions into
our way of life and our liberties and
the clearest example of that by the way
would be the
democrats in washington right now trying
to federalize elections take elections
away from states and local governments
have it run directly out of congress
they're using their mythology about
january 6th as an excuse that would be a
major overhaul of the way our democracy
works
so i'm going to assume that you're going
to disagree with the u.s capitol police
and their description of what happened
to officer brian signing and i'm going
to read what the u.s capitol police has
said about his death the u.s capitol
police accepts the finding from the
district of columbia's office of the
chief medical examiner that officer
brian sicknick died of natural causes
this does not change the fact that
officer siknik died in the line of duty
courageously defending congress and the
capital the department continues to
mourn the loss of our beloved colleague
the attack on our officers including
brian was an attack on our democracy do
you disagree with the u.s capitol police
on that statement
well obviously not because the u.s
capitol police admitted that the medical
examiner said that he died of natural
causes
so we entirely agree on that furthermore
we agree that officer brian signing was
a good faithful servant and defended his
country and that's a wonderful thing and
ought to be applauded i guess the only
place i would disagree with them is the
notion that the capital riot was some
some sort of singular attack on
democracy when you you've seen far more
egregious attacks from the left from
elected not just people in horn hats but
people who are now the president vice
president of the united states
encouraged by them uh people who are in
congress maxine waters saying get up in
the faces of republicans go to their
homes where their children sleep get up
push back on them say you're not welcome
here to pretend that somehow that's not
an assault on democracy but but some
midwestern father cracking a coors light
in the capital rotunda that nearly took
down the constitution give me a break
[Music]
[Music]
you